practicing how to keep the peace
britain's troops train alongside serbian
forces
in a country the uk once bombed as part
of a nato mission
now the two sides fight together against
fake terrorists
in a show of unity
but one of britain's real rivals russia
may eye this renewed friendship with
suspicion
the british defense secretary said the
balkans matter for the security of
europe
we don't come here to or any other part
of the world to
to sort of seduce or cause problems we
come here to
provide partnership could relations
between london
and moscow also eventually be fixed
ben wallace seems hopeful provided
russia's leader changes his ways
after a meeting this week with the u.s
president joe biden do you think
that might potentially be a summit at
some point between
vladimir putin and boris johnson yeah
look boris johnson is clearly open to
meet anyone
where there is an important step to be
made
and stepping towards normalizing
relations with russia
will obviously and hopefully come but
but it comes following certain actions
and you know
crimea is still illegally occupied in
ukraine
and there are still things to resolve
but you hope that could possibly happen
well look i i i don't want a permanent
uh friction between russia
and the west that is not in anybody's
engine but uh you know that's not cost
free you have to
lift that based on behaviors
as long as russia remains a threat
engaging with countries like serbia
where moscow has deep ties is
particularly important to the uk
who does serbia prefer to train with
with british forces or with russian
forces
well we are military neutral so we don't
have to prefer
to train with either we can choose both
and that's our advantage
the serbian defense minister hosted ben
wallace on this two-day tour
this is the first time a british defense
secretary has visited
serbia it's a sign of the uk's desire
to strengthen ties with a country it
hasn't always seen eye to eye with
in particular during the kosovo war more
than 20 years ago
[Music]
rewind back even further though and they
fought on the same side during both
world wars
a shared history that's not forgotten
debra haynes sky news at south base near
bajanavac
in serbia